it's a tough job market out there right
now it feels like everyone is either
being laid off furloughed stuck in a
dead end position at a job with no
prospects of career advancement or
working multiple jobs just to meet the
bills every month as you're slowly
driven into the ground if only somewhere
new was hiring somewhere exciting
somewhere where every day is an
adventure and you never truly know what
you can expect well lucky for you there
is such a place it's the scp foundation
and after a recent high casualty scp-682
breach they have plenty of new positions
open for go-getters just like you that's
why we put out a post on our community
page asking for the job at the scp
foundation you think you'd be best at
and your reasons for why and today we're
going to evaluate your answers and see
who's up to the task let's go javier
gomez de la santos said i don't know if
it counts but being on the part of
relocating safe scps that are
rehabilitated such as
scp-2273 would be a very wholesome
experience to see them enjoy human
company once more other than doctors and
security officers and you could get some
new extraordinary friendships such as
beletrov had with his psychiatrist we
thought we'd start this video off on a
nice wholesome one in any kind of broken
veil scenario it's natural that some of
the nicer anomalies like bellatroph the
reluctant dimension hopper and the
abdominable planet guy would be released
back into civilian life of course to get
a job helping this happen much like
alexei belitrov's psychiatrist you'd
likely need to be qualified in social
work psychology or psychiatry but it's
probably one of the more fulfilling jobs
you can get with the foundation
geologyhill123 said having an ma in
history i can see myself working as a
researcher into ancient anomalies and
finding their cultural origins plotting
the aristocrats family tree altogether
knowing the habsburg's lineage is more
of a shrub would be fascinating the
wanderers library sounds like a dream
come true as well
now this is a fun one seeing as
anomalies can manifest in everything
from ancient ruins like scp-2621
to extinct cultures like the davites to
twisted family lines like the
aristocrats taking a historical approach
to exploring scps is definitely a
valuable job and one perfectly suited to
people with a background in history just
be careful with some of those ancient
texts reading the wrong ones might lead
to certain strange mental and physical
changes suicune fan 123 i think that's
how you say it said i'd love to work in
virology within the foundation
specifically writing the reports for the
more math-minded folks in the field in
my experience they need the help
ensuring reports are clear concise and
useful would be my ideal placement dream
job and reality too virology is an
undeniably useful skill for work at the
scp foundation given the number of
terrifying viruses they deal with like
the incurable contagious zombie virus
scp-008 the sarkic nightmare that is
scp-610 the flesh that hates or the
considerably more technological
infection
scp-217 the clockwork virus and hey
somebody needs to write those reports
drew sklar said as an engineer i feel
like doing researching and development
for containment procedures would be so
interesting the conditions a cell has to
meet vary so much between scps and each
one is so strange and interesting that
it feels like a puzzle containment
specialists are a vital part of the
operations of the scp foundation
considering that containment is one of
their core principles it's an exciting
and intellectually stimulating job but
there's also a lot of pressure involved
knowing if you don't do your job right
you could be responsible for a breach
that leads to a huge number of deaths
for your fellow personnel the civilian
world and potentially even you we're
sure you'll do fine though no need to
stress celephone said personally i'd
want to work in amnestics you don't have
to interact with dangerous anomalies
just your fellow foundation co-workers i
doubt the job is anywhere near as insane
as research staff or mtf being a
foundation middle woman suits me just
fine in with the class a b amnestic and
out with a cognitohazard my friends that
is a great attitude and honestly there
are a lot of benefits to working
directly with amnestics fun fact every
time that we have a video that
underperforms we release an amnestic gas
onto our audience and release it again
later who knows how many times you've
listened to this sentence that you're
listening to right now
moving on tim west said i would go with
where my experience helps me excel at
the most i've been working as a pso
protective service officer for the
department of homeland security for some
years now i also worked as an armed
bouncer was trained in the use of force
defensive tactics trained with firearms
long guns and unarmed combat also
trained for bomb detection and use of
magneto meters for the scp foundation i
would apply for the security division
well tim you seem pretty much perfectly
qualified for the job when can you start
no seriously can you start right now
scp-106 just got out again and we really
need a hand getting him back under
control yeah it's an all hands on deck
situation oh no he's coming through the
wall oh god grant admiral batch said i'd
go for containment specialist a cult
selection as i am very well versed in
the occult as to where i'd exceed others
probably when it comes to rituals as i
have an interest in them and know a lot
about them including some let's say
practical experience
huh are we allowed to ask follow-up
questions because i'm now really really
curious about your occult experience
grand admiral batch we'll dispatch a
field agent shortly metaman said i don't
really know much about the rankings or
positions in the foundation but if there
was a job for deciding who or what gets
sent to where for testing i would do
that i could do cross-testing as well as
just having the ability to have my worst
enemies killed by an scp okay see
applications like this are why we do
background checks metaman you need to
ascend to the level of 05 council before
you can start using anomalies to
belligerently assassinate your enemies
without consequences doing it on any
level below that is more likely to get
you into some serious trouble with your
site director missingno said i'm
proficient with firearms and i've been
refurbishing weapons and doing some
pretty decent gunsmithing for parts that
i need or need fixed up for the past 10
years i'd have an undying loyalty to the
foundation and maybe have a chance to
work with some of that fancy anomalous
weaponry or just a hired mtf guard the
first would be fun or i could just be dr
bright's newest body or fodder for 682
whatever works well we appreciate the
fact that you're giving yourself a wide
range of options here especially
considering that being a vessel for dr
bright or fodder for scp-682 has a very
low barrier to entry but hey considering
that mtf operatives are often killed in
the line of duty it's likely that a
position will open up for you if you can
prove yourself ellis bellis13 said i
think i would be a researcher trying to
understand anomalies who seemingly break
the laws of physics and the universe i
am studying math and physics and
currently doing my bachelor's thesis on
quantum bits by understanding the
physics allowing the anomalies to behave
anomalously we could utilize the
knowledge to develop new cool
technologies we like your style ellis we
need people like you on the team just
make sure that while developing this new
physics spending technology you don't
wind up trapping yourself in the red
reality but hey at least you'll be able
to keep dr scranton company eric back
said i'd love to work with the technical
side of the whole foundation could be
anything from i.t to constructing the
containments used on scps yes please you
could act as a replacement for technical
director rosen seriously he's utterly
unbearable we need to get rid of that
jerk crizzy has said would probably be
an mtf mu-13 ghostbusters i've always
been fascinated with the supernatural
that of my sensitivity to the paranormal
and seemingly paranormal would
definitely make me a valuable asset to
the team you seem like a great fit for
the team we just hope that ghostbusting
makes you feel good psycho cobra gaming
said having a background in psychiatry i
immediately go to the idea that all the
stress and threat of constant death
would really weigh on the mind of the
employees i'm not sure if the foundation
has a psychiatric department but if i
could spearhead the creation of one then
i would be given the room to climb up
the hierarchy of the foundation i'm sure
dr bright must have ptsd from his
several deaths and the o5 council must
have some form of mental anguish from
their centuries of life oh yeah we
imagine it indicate that something is
very wrong if a seasoned foundation
employee doesn't have a little ptsd on
the books the scary thing is with some
of the poor folks at the scp foundation
them recounting their days might give
their therapists ptsd stonewood studios
said some kind of mechanical engineering
profession just being able to observe
anomalous tech would be incredible i'd
love to try to discern how 914 works or
spend my days trying to understand the
functionality of the numerous remnants
of the broken god this seems like a good
application of your interests and skills
and if you want to be even better at
engineering why not put yourself into
the scp-914 chamber and set it to very
fine just to see what happens you know
it's a fun time frank official said
honestly even just being a janitor would
satisfy me there's this sense of dread
knowing some sort of dangerous thing
could break out at any moment really
does get your blood pumping it's a bold
choice honestly all the danger and
stress of working for the scp foundation
without any of the clearance pay or
prestige you're playing 5d chess minty
said i'd like to be part of some kind of
foundation reintegration program where
the scps are taught to control their
powers and just get used to being less
deadly so they could re-enter human
society i just feel bad for the scps
being essentially put in cages some of
them need to hug barring that i just
sign up for the serpent's hand
considering that the scp foundation can
be a little
cold towards anomalies you may
eventually find yourself becoming
disheartened towards the foundation and
its practices at this point yes it seems
likely that an allegiance with the
serpent's hand would be a pretty
appealing prospect for you cat and otter
said i would enjoy some good old
low-risk humanoids have a nice chat with
them maybe a round of tennis with kane
iris and mr fish it would indeed be nice
to chat with some low-risk humanoids be
warned about mr fish though he's been
known to be a little salty on occasion
god that joke was bad pikeshade said i
suppose i would like to work as an
archivist in a records room cataloging
anomalies and updating files i do that
mostly in my irl job while also turning
old word document manuals into
educational videos so i could probably
also collaborate with doctors and
researchers in how to make training
videos for new d-classes and mtfs and
how to deal and approach certain scps
and or rival organizations
wait you want to make training and
informational videos about scps that
sounds to us like you want to be our
competition listen buddy we rule the fun
user-friendly infographic videos about
scp's game you don't want to step on our
turf we can be very aggressive
gabby said i think i would work in the
application and development of
containment which would be less
stressful for the scp my hope would be
to make more of the sapien scps
comfortable hopefully befriend a few i
would more than likely die within the
first week but i hope at least i'd make
someone or something smile the scp
foundation honestly needs more people
with a humanist approach like you there
are plenty of perfectly friendly sapien
anomalies who deserve to have a nice
comfortable pad while they're contained
by the scp foundation do we really want
god complaining about scoliosis because
of his unpleasant foundation caught
doesn't have enough padding just make
sure you exercise caution when selecting
the anomalies you decide to give the
fancy new digs to seeing some of them
might use it as a method of escape that
being said if we gave scp-106 or scp-049
a high-quality jacuzzi in each of their
cells do you think they might chill out
a little after all we've never really
tried making the containment chamber too
relaxing and chill to even want to leave
symphony in blue said i think it would
be cool if there was a position where
you just visited chilled with some of
the friendly scps especially those who
struggle with living and containment i
feel like it would be really helpful for
them and their general well-being and
mental health if they had someone who
wasn't explicitly a researcher or a
doctor but was rather just somebody to
talk to to chill out with and to give
them a little bit more normality might
help people be a little more comfortable
and happy in containment again this is
another pleasingly wholesome one a lot
of these anomalies could use a friend to
chat with dr gears isn't the most
scintillating conversationalist lol
chief 119 said i'd probably enlist in
mtf beta 7 the mass hatters because
there was always this deep fascination
about biohazard chemical and
radiological stuff that i've had for
many years now plus there is a great
chance i get to kill zombies maybe if i
ask the task force leader really nicely
maybe i can carry a barbed wire bat when
clubbing said zombies while deciding to
club anomalous zombies to death with a
negan style barbed wire bat would
definitely earn you some points with
other weird violent mavericks like dr
clef in all likelihood though you'd be
spending most of the time in a heavy
duty hazmat suit picking up dangerous
waste material in the aftermath of an
anomalous attack have fun
chocolate quill said i'm gonna be
completely real with y'all i'd like to
think i'd be a high level researcher for
the foundation but i'd probably get
demoted for wanting to play with scp-999
all the time we appreciate your honesty
and there are definitely worse things
you can get into trouble for doing at a
foundation containment site like that
one brony researcher who um
well you you know the story on that one
brody inch said while i'm not going to
lie i feel like i and scp-049 have a lot
in common not the fact that we are both
doctors or kind of evil but that we
share a personality and a lot of
mannerisms if there was a job to study
and interact with a single subject
that's right for me i also think it
would be pleasurable to learn from
scp-049 as we share a lot of mannerisms
there's a chance i could possibly become
a friend of sorts and he could tell me
all about how his bag works along with
the language he writes in hey that
sounds excellent we think scp-049 would
be elated to have a new friend to
discuss his thoughts and theories with
and having someone he sees as a peer
would be a great way to keep him mellow
and stop him from breaching containment
all the time maybe we found the solution
to one of our oldest
oh okay back to the drawing board i
guess emain abba said personally i would
like to be part of the ethics committee
they're probably the most powerful group
in the scp foundation besides the o5
council i'd be able to access knowledge
that most the staff can't the most
important part for me is that i'll be
able to make the experiments on the scps
and the d-class less violent they
deserve some rights as well wow we are
really learning that a lot of our fans
are surprisingly ethical people today it
truly warms our scp-058
and it's true the foundation really does
need the ethics committee to make sure
that these monster hunters never become
monsters themselves angel jaff benitez
said i'd love to work with anomalous
plants either in the bio research zone
or as a member of the gardeners i just
like plants that much even though i know
what some plants are capable of hey the
foundation needs plenty of botanists for
their wide variety of plant-based
anomalies and if you like your plants to
have a little bit of flesh on the side
you can head down to
scp-3989 the bone orchard for the best
of both worlds thorne wolfie said i'm an
animal caretaker with a bachelor's in
zoology so i'd likely be some kind of
cryptid keeper i do my best to ensure
the more beast-like scps were as
comfortable as possible in their
enclosure while maintaining security and
their safety as well as the rest of the
staff i'd likely also advocate a bit for
them try to keep too many inhuman
experiments from happening no cruelty
for cruelty's sake cryptid keeper is a
hell of a job title as long as you
remember to stay safe out there after
all some anomalies are more dangerous
than others and it's often rarely the
ones you think but we definitely respect
your commitment to keeping things humane
it's always the best way to go
wow what an incredible interview session
it's looking like the scp foundation is
going to have an awesome new stock of
employees on their hands once all that
paperwork is through and thanks to this
organization's incredibly high
turnaround we're sure that once all
these newbies are either nicely grizzled
or killed by an anomaly we'll get some
new fresh faces around here real soon be
sure to keep an eye on our community
page for the next chance to be a part of
one of these delightfully wacky videos
now go check out how to work at the scp
foundation explained and good vs evil
scp ethics committee orientation for
more information on jobs and the inner
workings of the scp foundation